The perfect childhood.
School is out.
Shoes are off.
You’re sprinting across the hot, sandy beach,
smiling for no apparent reason; because back
then you didn’t even need one.
Did I mention there’s an orange cone on
your head?
Where’d it come from?
Why is it there?
What is the point?
Do not think too deeply about it.
There is no room for symbolism in the summer.
There is no use overanalyzing the antics of
teenage youth.
It’s just a cone; and you are just a kid,
doing things for no other reason than that
you want to.
You’re busy living.
Doing your thing.
Responsibility is still years away.
Such a pretty picture we’re painting, isn’t
it?
But this is SCP Explained, so of course, by
now, you’ve figured out this is all a misdirection,
didn’t you?
Well, here it comes.
Watch closely.
Look at you run.
Moving toward nothing as if it means everything.
Look at that smile, the wind whipping through
the gap in your teeth.
Soak it in.
In twenty years, your face muscles will have
forgotten the movement.
Look at you live!
Yes, go on, soak it in.
You will be chasing this feeling your whole
life while moving further and further away
from it.
Oof.
Depressing, isn’t it?
We think so too.
But here is the silver lining, something you’d
be wise to celebrate…
At least you have this moment to look back
on.
The memory is with you forever.
Not everyone is so lucky.
Not everyone has a good childhood.
Furthermore, not everyone even has a childhood
at all.
Some live beyond the expectations of age.
Imagine a fourteen-year-old forced to be forty.
That is not to say they have to pay taxes
or can run for senate.
No.
This level of forced maturity that I'm speaking
of transcends the scope of average adulthood.
So, let’s not imagine a kid going through
the mundane life of a cubicle junkie: filing
papers, pretending to work, and answering
phone calls.
Instead, let’s do this.
Imagine a kid going to war.
Imagine a kid carrying out stealth assassination
missions.
Imagine a kid being locked in containment
living with little human interaction and freedom.
This is all to say, imagine a kid…not being
a kid at all.
Now, this is more like an SCP Explained.
This is the sad story of someone who had to
say goodbye to the joys of adolescence earlier
than anyone ever should have to.
In fact, they didn’t even get to say goodbye
at all.
This is the story of SCP-105.
Now, to be clear, SCP–105 is not a blood-thirsty
demon living in the shadows.
It is not an un-squishable spider dancing
across your hardwood floor, mocking the soles
of your shoes as they stomp down with no success.
It is not a grand piano in a hotel lobby absorbing
the DNA of all who touch its keys.
And it is not a freezer that tempts late-night
snackers to reach deeper and deeper toward
an ever-elusive hot fudge sundae until they
are sucked in, frozen solid, sold for millions,
and displayed as decorative ice sculptures
atop the center of punch bowls at parties
for rich politicians.
No.
We’ll just have to get to those on a different
day.
Because SCP-105 is just… how do I put this…
a girl.
Yes, a small, unremarkable-looking girl.
At the time of acquisition, she was just 1.54
meters tall and weighed 50kg.
Even those of you listening with little to
no instinctual senses for converting meters
and kilograms to feet and pounds can still
understand this is no frightful giant we’re
talking about.
Lining up a class by height, she’d blend
in somewhere toward the middle.
And if you look even closer, beyond the shallow
surface of measurements and toward the details
of her face, even still, you won’t find
a single freckle to fear.
SCP-105 has blue eyes and blonde hair.
Nothing coastal Californians haven’t seen
a million times over just this Monday.
Formally known as Iris Thompson, SCP-105 has
no discernable oddities.
If you saw her jumping rope, you wouldn’t
point and stare.
If you saw her at the park playing with your
children, you wouldn’t pull them away and
squeeze them tight.
If you saw her walking toward you on the sidewalk,
you wouldn’t turn around and run away in
the other direction.
By herself, SCP-105 is not too different from
anyone else.
No matter how close we zoom in on her appearance,
personality, or her tendencies there is nothing
to see that triggers alarms.
If you ask her to spit fire, she won’t.
If you conduct a lab experiment where she
has to find the exit of a maze using only
her sense of smell, she will get lost and
fail.
This is all to say, if you look too closely
through the microscope at SCP-105, you might
miss her anomalous abilities.
Instead, you’d be better off taking a step
back and just watching her live her life.
And that is all that she wanted to do: live
her life.
Is that so much to ask?
The first thing you will notice is that she
isn’t alone.
And like in any good buddy-buddy film, her
counterpart reveals more to her character.
So who is standing by her side?
Who is the co-star of this film that pushes
our protagonist into The Foundation’s spotlight?
Well, it’s no person at all.
It’s a camera, her camera.
SCP-105-B is a Polaroid One Step Express,
manufactured in 1982.
It does not appear to have any out-of-the-ordinary
physical characteristics and appears to be,
for all intents and purposes, a normal Polaroid
camera, operating as expected for all persons
aside from SCP-105.
When you point it at a subject, they don’t
get sucked into the lens.
The flash can’t blind an army of soldiers.
When you say cheese, it doesn’t shoot out
a brick of cheddar.
The camera is nothing more than a camera.
That is, until in the hands of Iris Thompson.
What’s more unique than the camera itself
are the photographs it produces.
When SCP-105 holds a photograph taken by SCP-105-B,
the picture changes from a still shot to that
of a real-time image of the person, location,
or object photographed.
Regardless of the subject of the photograph,
the image will convert itself into what appears
to be a handheld Livestream of whatever was
pictured.
Imagine a photograph of a waterfall.
If held by SCP-105, you do not just see the
image of a waterfall, but you will physically
see the water falling, splashing down onto
the rocks below.
It is similar to holding your cell phone and
watching a GIF, however, instead of just watching,
Iris is able to interact with it in a way
beyond any technology has ever allowed.
SCP-105 is then able to move her arm through
and into the photograph and manipulate objects
within reach of the original point at which
the photograph was first taken.
Yes, you heard me right.
SCP-105-2 doesn’t just offer Iris quick
prints of memories…it gives her much more,
granting her access to a new dimension.
Although this is clearly a unique situation
for Iris, it doesn’t mean that Iris is the
only one affected by this anomaly.
When she engages with the photographs, it
actually affects the world attached to them.
That is to say, there are consequences to
her actions.
Every photograph she has ever taken is essentially
a portal to a world of problems.
Witnesses who have been on the other side
of the photograph while SCP-105 was manipulating
it, report seeing her hand reaching out from
an invisible portal and carrying whatever
actions she pleases.
Once her arm is inside the photograph, she
has the freedom to control the image as she
wishes.
This ability has obvious benefits for anyone.
Imagine being able to carry around with you
a photograph of your oven.
Then, whenever you get that paranoid feeling
that you forgot to turn it off, you can reach
into the polaroid and turn the dial how you
please.
But the peace of mind is just a small benefit
of this power, and it’s easy to assume that
anyone would be tempted to use their abilities
for far more than just controlling at-home
kitchen appliances while on vacation.
The Foundation, specifically, concerns itself
with bigger, more ambitious uses of anomalous
power.
And the power, in this case, wasn’t just
in the camera.
While 105-B helps Iris use her powers most
efficiently, she is still able to manipulate
objects through photographs taken by other
cameras, though not quite as well as when
she’s using her favorite camera.
Noting that 105-B and the photographs taken
by said camera have no unusual properties
when used by any other person except for SCP-105,
it was clear to The Foundation who the greater
anomaly in the situation really was.
The tool wasn’t of their interest, but rather
the person wielding it.
But how did this all come to their attention?
Is The Foundation really investigating the
life of a girl playing with a camera in her
bedroom?
Well, some moments are just too big to be
bound by privacy.
SCP-105 was brought to the forefront of The
Foundation's attention shortly after the murder
of her boyfriend.
Promptly after his death, the police investigated
the scene and looked for answers.
And when looking for answers, they started
conjuring up questions.
One of which put Iris at the center of their
search.
“Where were you?”
Her response wasn’t so straightforward.
She wasn’t there, but then she was.
The police pressed further, not understanding.
SCP-105 explained that she was at home, but
once she learned of his death, she hurried
over to him.
This left the police even more suspicious,
as there was no way she could have been informed
of the murder by an outside source.
She must have been there all along.
Seeing the skepticism in their faces, SCP-105
scrambled for an explanation.
She took a deep breath and got her story straight.
She claimed to have been on the phone with
her boyfriend at the time of the violent attack,
and once she heard the commotion, it prompted
her to hurry over to his location, where she
saw him dead.
This excuse made logical sense, and so the
police dropped their suspicion.
After all, Iris was just a small, innocent
teenager.
However, just as quickly as the police moved
on from Iris, they returned to her, this time
with tangible proof of their doubts.
The telephone records did not correspond to
her story.
She was never on the phone with her boyfriend
that night.
It was then that SCP-105 had to confess.
She informed her lawyer that she had, in fact,
been there for the murder.
Well, not there… but… kinda there.
She explained how she witnessed the murder
through a photograph she had taken with her
boyfriend several days prior.
The attorney in question disregarded the story
and recommended that the subject plead guilty.
Iris, however, refused to do so.
She was sticking to her truth, no matter how
crazy it made her seem.
She went forward and told her story in court.
It was met with derision.
The judge and the jury didn’t even entertain
the possibility of any of it being true.
Iris was flustered.
She was a young teenage girl fighting for
her freedom, her only weapon being the truth.
But the room wasn’t participating in her
reality.
They dismissed her as crazy.
And so when Iris offered to demonstrate her
ability, it was the last straw.
The judge wouldn’t allow Iris to waste any
more of anyone’s time.
She was sentenced to a psychiatric ward.
Iris was determined to get out of there.
She knew she didn’t belong.
Luckily, someone else knew, too, that she
didn’t belong.
And because of this, in a matter of days she
was out of there.
But home wasn’t where she was heading.
No.
It wasn’t mom and dad picking her up from
the psychiatric ward, but rather the Foundation
breaking her out, stealing her for themselves,
and bringing her to site-17.
There at site-17, Foundation Personnel began
their mission, which started with trying to
convince SCP-105 that they were on her side.
They began by retrieving SCP-105-B from SCP-105's
home and replacing it with an identical model,
only then to give it to her under the lie
that it was the original.
The lies wouldn’t stop just there.
They’d continue to pour over her reality
until it was impossible for her to recognize
one from the other.
SCP-105's parents were informed that she was
killed during the botched escape of another
patient while both were in the custody of
a psychiatric care facility.
In truth though, the Foundation wants nothing
more than to keep SCP-105 alive.
However, they are not concerned about the
quality of her living.
Iris was a tool for The Foundation.
She was an asset.
She was a secret weapon.
She had powers they could have only dreamed
of, only now they existed.
But before shooting their new shiny weapon,
they needed to learn how to use it properly.
But with what manual?
How do you learn how to use another human?
Well, having seen enough Marvel movies, they
knew they would be better equipped with knowledge
if they understood her origin story.
So they began questioning Iris, trying to
get to the root cause of her anomalous aptitude.
She was either ten or eleven.
She remembers because she was looking at a
picture of the ocean, and she noticed that
the waves began moving.
Her parents said that she just had an overactive
imagination.
When she first was able to move objects in
the photos, she was eleven, twelve, maybe.
Her family took a trip to the Grand Canyon.
She looked through the photo album after they
got home, and she brushed her hand up against
one by accident.
When she did, she pushed a rock over the edge,
falling into the canyon; she could actually
hear it clatter on the way down.
She became fascinated with photography after
that.
Most of the time, it didn't work with photographs
she took, but her parents got her a Polaroid
One Step Express camera that she’d been
begging them for since Christmas.
After she got the camera, the photos got easier
to interact with.
After hearing her story, the researcher made
her an offer.
She’d be allowed certain freedoms if she
agreed to use her powers to do them a few
favors.
She could, at least in some capacity, act
her age, socialize, and do things a girl her
grade would normally do.
But in exchange, she had to first do things
that nobody any age should ever have to do.
Iris agreed.
And it was in this agreement that we see just
how desperate she was during her childhood.
She was willing to risk everything for something
as small as a quick conversation with a guard,
five minutes of jump rope, or simply a few
minutes spent under the sun.
She was assigned to be a part of Mobile Task
Force Omega-7 to carry out a wide range of
missions.
And if the fate of the first humanoid SCP
recruited to Mobile Task Force Omega-7 was
any indication of how this might play out,
Iris was in a lot of trouble.
The Pandora's Box initiative had a history
of failure.
Their previous efforts under "Team Able" ended
in the death of absolutely everyone.
However, “Team Iris” began on a more hopeful
note.
They carried out different missions than “Team
Able.”
Instead of violent attacks, their primary
missions were reconnaissance and intelligence
gathering.
However, just because there were no swords
and blood drawn, the missions were not so
harmless.
Despite "Team Iris" carrying out over twenty
jobs in cooperation with the Bowe Commission,
swiftly and without incident, their streak
eventually had to come to an end.
The first disciplinary incident for SCP-105
involved the escalation of Team Iris missions
from reconnaissance to assassinations.
Yes, this teenage girl with not a violent
bone in her body was tasked to kill.
Note that her only power is that of manipulating
photos.
In her mind, this is nothing more than a party
trick.
It was a gift she was born with, and she was
always aware that it was unique, but never
did she expect it to be a curse.
She liked being able to straighten books in
photographs of libraries.
She liked being able to reach into photos
and hug her teddy bear that she no longer
has.
She liked being able to help, heal, and embrace
history…not alter it.
SCP-105 violently opposed the use of her abilities
to carry out assassinations.
They wanted her to murder people, and like
any girl of her nature would, she resisted.
But they kept pressing.
While some teenage girls are pressured by
parents to play sports they don’t particularly
care for, this one was pressured to kill.
During these events, SCP-105 became emotionally
distressed and attempted to deceive Foundation
personnel into believing that her anomalous
traits had disappeared.
She claimed she couldn’t carry out the missions
anymore.
Her doctor submitted a report recommending
that SCP-105 be re-classified as Neutralized,
undergo amnestic treatment, and be released
to the public with regular monitoring.
After further investigation, The Foundation
realized the doctor was prioritizing SCP-105’s
emotional state over the goals of The Foundation.
They had built a friendship.
He was the one telling her to pretend not
to have powers anymore.
This was all found out.
Thus, his recommendation to release Iris was
denied.
With nothing to lose at that point, the doctor
even helped Iris try to escape The Foundation’s
custody.
But this failed.
She was captured and the doctor was promptly
discharged.
At that point, Iris had to start over again
to regain the trust of The Foundation.
In yet another compromise, she re-demonstrated
her anomalous abilities in exchange for the
restoration of limited privileges: nothing
more than occasionally being allowed to jump
rope, getting a lollipop every Thursday, and
being informed of the recent trends on Tik
Tok.
And so this is where we know her to be.
Continuously making sacrifices in exchange
for tiny teaspoons of teenage life.
All the while she is growing older and older,
unfulfilled by the years she passes.
And so while it is easy to look back on our
childhood with lust and longing, at least
it was there, and is still there now, safely
stored in our memory, stored in the protection
of the past.
For Iris, this is not so.
Her childhood is both behind her and in front
of her.
It is something she moved on from too quickly.
And it is a future she fights for every day.
Even when she is ninety-seven, gray, decrepit,
and on her deathbed, she will be sacrificing
her freedoms to feel fifteen.
And so we have to wonder, is SCP-105 a danger
to anyone at all?
I leave you with a question.
Are we more likely to be attacked by a dog…or
the master holding its leash?
Now go check out “SCP-053 - Young Girl”
and “SCP-3082 - Neverland's Lost Boys and
Girls” for more peculiar anomalous children!